the salmon not very good not very fresh
the rice no seasoning
who buy japanese food from british
grocery store
i don't buy cottage pie from chinatown
higher hello niece and nephew it's
uncle roger this is snack war europe
versus
asia for lead bible okay bring on the
snack
i didn't even know europe has snack they
just have bed and
sausage oh
what is this can of condensed milk oh no
it's rice pudding
what is rice pudding this is so sad this
is the kind of stuff you feed your kid
after you divorce
are you sure you can just eat like this
no need to cook
uncle roger don't want to get diarrhea
come to lead piper
do snack walk get food poisoning hi
not worth it you're not even paying
uncle roger
i'm not myself for free how gross is
this oh my god
not appetizing is this the european food
because this looks like what you eat in
communist russia
look at this
very sweet hmm ankara not a fan
english snack it tastes like english
snack
oh uncle roger excited for this
see so much more appetizing the texture
you don't even need to eat this is
already more appealing
can i have different spoon because this
one is tainted by this
disgusting thank you thank you we need
to start with fresh spoon
a lot of peanuts uncle roger love peanut
very very good not even competition this
one
winner of this round what is this
this is the biker eat in office
you dip carrot into this you call this
snack hi
uh that's actually tara masalata tara
what
tara masalata cara masalata
what is this language hi white people
love doing this
they take something not white and they
make it white put different name
this one tastes a bit weird there's a
hummus and tuna
if you eat this in the office everybody
will hate you if you microwave this in
the office
everybody will hate you i think you got
this sushi from pharmacy
from boots because this sushi look like
toy
look at this tesco sushi hi
the salmon not very good not very fresh
the rice no seasoning
who buy japanese food from british
grocery store
i don't buy cottage pie from chinatown
hi
this one need to go to hummus but only
because you buy tesco sushi
oh no noodle and
instant rice this one pot noodle
oh english pot noodle okay
is this what british people think noodle
is
[Music]
actually okay not bad you caught this
egg fire rice
you have terrible taste in egg fried
rice this thing
look at how look at how lifeless the
rice is
all clumped together
tasteless the egg tastes like rubber
i have to give this one to the british
bread but only because
you handicap the asian snack just like
the sushi situation
all over again next snack
oh it's drink this one scottish
uncle roger no everybody in scotland
they love this
iron brew or something
what flavor is this they don't even say
what flavor they just tell you it's
orange
mmm okay not mad not bad just like
regular soda taste this one from
thailand
lychee drink uncle roger love lychee it
is the best fruit
this really good
i love this this is the best thailand
win
hand down
hi uh hi uh hi
uh hi uh hi
oh bro what that smells like [ __ ] ass
am i eating arse juice what is this
nigeria what are you doing